[Music]  Teen Mom star Katelyn Lowell Baltierra  is pregnant with her third child  okay the reality star shared the happy  news with fans on Monday's episode of  Teen Mom og Kaitlyn and her husband  Tyler Baltierra  share a three-year-old daughter nobly  and our biological parents - Carly whom  they gave up for adoption on Monday's  episode Kaitlyn surprised her man by  dressing Nova in a pink t-shirt reading  I'm going to be a big sister well the  couple has been open about their journey  to have more kids on Teen Mom with the  25 year old sharing her fears of  becoming pregnant again after struggling  with postpartum depression Kaitlyn  re-entered rehab  earlier this month just two weeks after  she returned home from six weeks of  treatment for having suicidal thoughts